[موسيقى]
الشهر الثاني من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بشهر فبراير وهو الشهر الاقصر في
السنه في عدد ايامه 28 يوما بس انها
البسيطه و 29 يوم بسنه الكبيسه ولا يصير
29 يوما الا مره واحده الاربعه سنين فالذي
يولد يوم 29 ما يحتفل بيوم ميلاده الا مره
واحده كل اربع سنين وفبراير ماخوذه من
اللفظه السريانيه هيبرس والتي تعني الهه
النقاء والصفاء ويسمى بالعراق وبلاد الشام
بشباط وهي لفظه سريانيه تعني الشده والضرب
يقعوا فيه وشباط شديد في رياحه ويضرب بشده
في بارده ولا ننسى ان شباط ما على كلامه
رباط وشباب ومقطع رباط
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر فبراير في اوله موسم بذره الست وهي
الايام السته الصالحه لزراعه جميع
المحاصيل شتويه كانت ام صيفيه وفي منتصفه
عقرب الدم والتي سميت بهذا لان بردها يدمي
ولا يقتل وفي نهايته موسم السحب الصيفيه
المسماه بسه حب المراويح او السرايات وهي
سحبا تتخلق بشده وتهطل بغزاره والعامه
يسمون الشخص الحار واللي يجيب حاصله بسرعه
فلان سحابه
[موسيقى]